a young Pearl in high school and we had  this Chastity speaker and I was thinking  like basically she went up and she said  I got ran through but then I found God  you know praise God and then the husband  was like and then the husband was like  oh yeah and I I found her after this and  like I was a virgin and I waited and she  and it's oh and I realized I was like  it's always the women who didn't wait  and I'm like oh it's like they're kind  of marketing you can be a hoe and then  find a husband like it's like a  marketing like scale I don't think they  mean to but I'm like oh it's like that's  what they're marketing to young women  and I remember like wanting to like ask  this question but Catholic School  couldn't handle it